suicide is the leading cause of death
for those between the ages of 10 and 18
in our state according to the cdc
a rising concern among health leaders
especially during the pandemic
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the troubling trend
and the efforts to address it the
pandemic is highlighting mental health
right now and
health leaders in southern nevada are
noticing more children
seeking help this is definitely a
significant increase
over uh you know what i'm used to john
dewer works with patients admitted to
seven hills hospital
coming in with you know severe
depression
anxiety self-harm the director of
clinical services tells me
more children are making statements
about suicidal thoughts now
he also notices a new age trend among
those seeking treatment
we used to be kind of more familiar with
12 and up and now it's creeping down
you know a few few years mental health
remains a challenge the community wants
to address
the nevada parent teacher association
recently hosted a webinar on suicide
prevention
it's an epidemic we're dealing with the
clark county school district also
focusing on it
the board of trustees approved spending
761 thousand dollars to buy a mental
health program for
students and staff there's a greater
need
that has been before the pandemic now we
have a tool
that is a resource for our families
lawmakers plan to tackle the growing
problem at this legislative session
senate bill 36 requires every school
board to create a committee dedicated to
developing a plan for responding to a
crisis
emergency or suicide but doer recommends
families start the conversations at home
talk to him about it in a very
direct and normalizing way to
potentially save a child's life
kristin drummond 8 news now
the clark county coroner's office
reports 16 people taking their lives so
far this year in kids between the age of
17
and younger 12 students in ccsd
have died by taking their own lives
since august